you
19:07 was a time when einstein was
really basking in the glow of having
already discovered what we call the
special theory of relativity material
that we'll touch on a little later
tonight
various insights into nature space and
time and he set himself around that time
the goal of understanding an even bigger
mystery the force of gravity now you
need to know around 1907 in fact way
before that many physicists believed
that gravity was pretty much understood
from the work of Isaac Newton however
Einstein was of course the kind of
thinker for whom there was no such thing
as received wisdom that he wasn't
willing to challenge willing to think
through in fresh new ways and in
particular when he was thinking about
the force of gravity that everybody was
aware of and thought that we understood
well he asked a very simple and basic
question that no one seemed to have the
answer to and that question was how does
gravity really work how is it that one
object in the universe like the Sun can
somehow exert a pull on another object
like the earth even though there's
nothing connecting them there's
effectively empty space between them how
does gravity get the job done so
naturally to try to answer that question
Einstein went to the Principia Newton's
Principia which has all the results in
math and physics that Newton found in
his lifetime you know it was the is the
book that was required reading for
tonight's discussion
in of course the original Latin now of
course you know most of you therefore
know of the story but for the one or two
who maybe didn't quite finish the
reading let me just carry on so so
Einstein went over to the pre capilla he
opens it up to letter G you know finds
the law of gravity the Newton had
written down late 1600s and then it goes
a little further to the subheading M for
the mechanism by which gravity operates
and there Einstein finds something
surprising because Newton basically says
I don't know how gravity works I've been
able to write down an equation that
seems to govern its influence but if you
ask me how it actually gets the job done
I don't know in fact in his own words he
said to the answer of that important
question the mechanism by which gravity
operates Newton said I leave it to the
consideration of the reader
most readers at that point would simply
read on here is where Einstein was
different he spent 10 long years trying
to figure out how gravity works and he
finally did come to the answer with his
so-called general theory of relativity
and let me just quickly describe to you
what he found because it sets the stage
for this idea of there possibly being
more than three dimensions of space how
does it go
what's einstein's idea well the idea is
often described in a metaphor that you
perhaps have heard before let me
describe and then I'll show you a visual
forget about the universe and gravity
for a moment instead imagine that I have
a big rubber sheet stretch nice and taut
in front of me in your mind's eye you
can watch a marble as it rolls across
the surface of that rubber sheet it goes
in a straight line trajectory nothing
too weird about it but now if I change
things a little bit I put a rock on the
rubber sheet now this sheet looks like
this it's warped it's curved it's
deformed if I take the same marble it
won't go in the same straight line
trajectory any longer now it will go in
a curved trajectory because it's rolling
on the curved surface of the sheet
Einstein says take that idea and apply
it to the universe the fabric of space
not a rubber sheet but the fabric of
space and what would that look like it
would look like this so if we go out
into the cosmos and use this as a
representation of three-dimensional
space which is a little hard to work
with so let me do it will often do
tonight go to a two-dimensional analog
that we can picture better space like
the rubber sheet is nice and flat when
nothing is there but if the Sun appears
the fabric of space curves similarly in
the vicinity of the earth the fabric of
space curves and now focus your
attention on the moon because this is
the main point the moon is kept in orbit
because it's rolling along a valley in
the curved environment that the earth
creates that Einstein says is how
gravity is communicated from place to
place warps and curves in the fabric of
space the earth to kept in orbit because
it is rolling along a valley in the
curved environment that the Sun creates
that is how gravity works